量子コンピューターは、従来のコンピューターでは
解決できない問題に取り組もうとしています。
たとえば、炭素回収を実現するための
適切な素材を見つけること、
気候変動との戦いに本格的に挑むこと、
地球を傷つけない、より効率的な肥料の開発、
そして世界を養うために必要な
食料サプライチェーンの維持といった課題です。
さらに、宇宙の構造や物質が
原子・素粒子レベルでどのように振る舞うかという
根本的な問いもあります。これらは解明が必要です。
まさに次のフロンティアです。
すでに研究が進んでいる分野を一つ見てみましょう。
新しいバッテリーの探索です。
バッテリーは、コンピューターやスマートフォンを
持ち運べるようにすることで私たちの生活を変えました。
しかし、まだやるべきことがあります。バッテリーは
クリーンエネルギーの未来に欠かせないものです。
電気自動車への電力供給にせよ、
再生可能エネルギーの普及促進にせよ、
根本的に異なる化学が必要です。
次世代のバッテリーを作るために。
量子コンピューティングがあれば、
バッテリー内部の非常に複雑な反応を効果的に観察し、
新しい素材を考案したり、
バッテリーの構造について検討したりすることが
次世代デバイスの電力供給に
必要になるでしょう。
どうすれば実現できるのでしょうか。世界最先端の量子
デバイスと開発プラットフォームを構築し、
それを世界に公開することです。
今まさに協力し合うことでのみ、
将来直面するであろう問題を
共に解決できるようになります。